la pyramide du louvre c'est lui yao ming
bay l'architecte américain de renom
présente son projet en 1984 comme
bientôt une pyramide donc inauguré
quatre ans plus tard par celui qui a
commandé ce projet le président françois
mitterrand est comme ça chante organiser
les formes autour d'une esthétique entre
l'annoncé du projet en 84 et
l'inauguration en 88 paris s'est déchiré
autour de la pyramide
l'irruption de l'art moderne dans le
palais du louvre
de plus par un architecte étrangers une
hérésie pour certains la maquette à
peine présenté le courrier des lecteurs
du journal le monde s'enflamme
nous voici obligés de subir le diktat
d'un étranger cette pyramide de
pacotille comme une verrue sur un lob
visage sur place aussi il y à des bars
de nuit ça va être donné que donnera le
vert au bout de quelques années mais je
conçois bien la pyramide
la presse aussi prend position c'est le
cas d'andré fermigier chroniqueur
urbanisme et architecture au monde
il parle d'une maison des morts dans le
journal mais il est bien le seul de cet
avis dans la rédaction
tellement isolés qu'il quitte son poste
et rejoint une association opposée à la
pyramide
quand je regarde la matte la maquette je
vois d'abord cette pyramide qui me
paraît une agression absolument
insupportable le site du lourd est la
plus forte à gré sur je crois dont a été
victime un monument historique depuis 50
ans pas de polémique sans rumeurs et la
pyramide a eu les siennes
l'édifice symboliserait la franc
maçonnerie et elle serait composée de
666 carreaux diabolique
pour calmer les ardeurs il faut attendre
1988 que la pyramide sortent de terre le
29 mars 1989 le public peut enfin voir
la pyramide d'en bas je trouve que c'est
très aéré biens exportés
très grande très bien et ça permet de
voir les oeuvres d'art mais il ne
faudrait pas en dire trop de biens non
plus
[Musique]